so what are you doing uh music wise
what's next for you so i got a couple
tracks that i just released hip hop uh
real one real number one not the word
and uh i got cinematic universe and m
and j as if eminem and jay-z renegade
so it's a play on those
uh that song renegade in the great
record on the blueprint man that record
kind of changed my life when i was a kid
i remember i was a sophomore playing
varsity football and i was riding around
with the seniors you know going to the
games on friday night lights we were
playing on saturday you know they were
like looking for a fight you know the
other teams are all going like the
friday night game
and i was in the car and they played
renegade it just came out
and they had that [ __ ] bumping in the
car we were on our way i felt like a
badass you know a young kid like with
the older uh seniors you know
going to look for a fight and i just
remember
it never got better
meaning just rap music
i just like
i'm here now like it that that was it
yeah i remember that moment it never got
better never had another one of those
it never got better i may have had a few
of those but nothing better man because
uh renegade was [ __ ] unbelievable and
uh two guys that influenced me so much
um and and a lot of you know the persona
and the yellow hair right eminem and
[ __ ] and uh talking [ __ ] on the mic and
you know eight mile the movie and
and uh jay-z went gave me
i went to college because of jay-z
listen to his music
open up businesses mm-hmm i i got i i
put money aside i had business plans i i
looked at my circle and said no not you
right yeah you it's like he was he was
giving game the whole time he was
cutting records and
i loved that and i and i love hip-hop
and i owe a lot you get the [ __ ]
wu-tang logo on your body yeah man you
know what's cool about that man i'll
remember uh
so i'm at rolling level my little
brother's shooting it he's on stage he's
filming travis scott travis scott's
going out and everybody wants me to
stick around for travis but they're
playing at the same time as wu-tang and
i was like uh [ __ ] travis scott no
offense i'm going to watch wu tang yeah
not that i don't like travis yeah great
music but i like wu tang better yeah
sorry fair enough yeah so i [ __ ]
i got everybody mad at me for this right
and i remember being so pissed off you
know and like it just had a shitty day
at rolling loud it was like [ __ ] this
place
so
uh you know it's just like a [ __ ]
backstage was just a [ __ ] show you know
what i'm saying a rolling loud backstage
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show [ __ ] show of a
place [ __ ] show and i was just like i'm
[ __ ] over this for sure terrible all
i wanted to do was see wu tang and i had
to wait this whole [ __ ] day for this
so now everybody's trying to drag me to
travis i'm like nah so i go see wu tang
and i'm on side stage and i'm standing
there and i'm watching them [ __ ] like
20 feet away and i'm rapping along i'm
just loving it
i've never met mutang i hear wu tang
likes wrestling but i've always heard
that but don't know you know and in all
my years i've met mother [ __ ] dude
jerry seinfeld gotten to know dave
chappelle gotten to know jeff ross some
great comedians got to know some actors
the weekend and you know met drake and
like i met some [ __ ] right
bro nothing was like this
i i was speechless and it's hard to get
me speechless it's hard to get me at a
loss for words but as they're getting
off stage
i'm like god damn i'd love to meet one
of the guys from wu tang just any one of
them [ __ ] rolls behind rank water
[ __ ] met whatever
and all of a sudden meth looks up and
goes yo enzo and i was like
he came up to me asked me for a picture
and you could see in the picture on my
phone i have tears in my eyes
i was so like
i made it that was like my i made it
moment like method yeah it could have
been anyway it could have been anybody
else dog no this was like my i made it
moment right i was like dog method man
knows who i am
like [ __ ] wu-tang after tattoo here
like [ __ ] meth knows me so i was that
was cool but uh i i usually never get
shook or rattled by anyone that was that
i think it was just the climax of a [ __ ]
you day that just finally came out it
made it all worth it you went through
this day for this moment yes and that's
what like welled up tears in my eyes
it's like it was all worth being here at
the [ __ ] show yeah rolling route is a
fun day but it's a long day and it's uh
yeah it was hot out dude i was wearing
pants was it out here [ __ ]
i know it was it was in queens oh yeah
i was a nightmare